jojo siwa is out
and proud and not taking no for an
answer it's just awesome
the 18 year old entertainer graces the
cover of entertainment weekly's digital
pride issue
where she opens up about coming out
publicly earlier this year
and why she's trying to have a scene
kissing a man removed from her upcoming
movie
bounce the nickelodeon star tells ew
quote
i'm madly in love and i do not want to
kiss another human
especially because it's a man jojo says
her wish to get the scene cut
also stems from her fans and how they
perceive her
quote that's what they look at me as not
some character not some fictional thing
and so it's going to be a little weird
of course it's
people are gonna say it's not normal but
it's your normal jojo is currently
dating girlfriend kylie prue
which she announced on the tonight show
with jimmy fallon shortly after coming
out as a member of the lgbtq plus
community in january
because it is true i do have the most
amazing
wonderful perfect most beautiful
girlfriend
on their one-month anniversary jojo
introduced kylie on instagram
describing her as the most loving
supportive happiest protective
and just the most beautiful perfect
person in the world a similar sentiment
she shared during her speech
at the 2021 glaad media awards i have
the best most amazing wonderful
girlfriend in the entire world who makes
me
so so so happy and that is all that
matters
i think it's really cool now that kids
all around the world
who who look up to me can now see
that loving who you want to love is
totally
awesome when it comes to living life as
our most authentic self
jojo tells the mag quote literally
everyone on planet earth reached out to
her to show their support
including kim kardashian lilna's ex and
iggy azalea who texted jojo writing
oh my god i'm so happy for you this is
amazing
i think coming out has this stigma
around it that it's a
really really really scary thing
but it's not anymore there's so many
accepting
and loving people out there and as far
as the direction of her music goes
jojo reveals she wants her next album to
be a gay pop
[Music]
record
[Music]
she says last year she told her
producers i want to create gay pop
and i want to have a concert for the
girls and for the gays
turns out a year later i'm very much so
gay
[Music]
with movies and music on the horizon no
doubt 2021 is shaping up to be a busy
year for the triple threat
but despite being super busy jojo
explained to et last year how she
manages her career
and life this is a lot for someone any
age
let alone being a teenager it is
exhausting and it is tiring
but i love that like that
feeling makes me like want to keep going
like i know like i'm so tired
i want to work for one more hour so i
can say i did it like that's like how my
brain works
but i also like as exhausting as it is
it doesn't require a lot of
mental thinking it's like so just
what it is it is who i am like there's
not like any meeting where i'm like okay
i gotta think like do i wear blue
sequins or pink sequins
what would the brand do it's like i am
the brand there's not a brand i
literally am the brand it's like
i want to wear a pink sequins with a
unicorn that's blue and purple on it
like it just like comes to me
you